[Music]
[Music]
in 1700s at the height of the Mughal
Empire under emperor aurangzeb the
Tamura dynasty as they called themselves
ruled nearly the entire Indian
subcontinent it was the largest most
powerful Muslim empire in the world it
was also the wealthiest empire in the
world a quarter of the global commercial
activity flowed through the Asian
subcontinent and the Mughal emperor
sovereignty became a dominant fixture of
Indian political and cultural life yet
within three generations mu called power
and prestige would be clipped by
commercial trading company from England
the Empire lost its central Imperial
will and indeed its ability to enforce
rule of course this raises the question
how did this come about does it move
halls decline were they conquered taken
over well as you've probably guessed the
answer is rather more complex in this
lecture we're going to examine how one
of the most vibrant commercial centers
in the global economy drifted towards
colonialism and how to set the stage for
an eventual conquest of India by either
by a regional Indian or indeed a foreign
power first we're going to look at more
closely at the regionalization of the
Mughal Empire in the 1700s second we'll
proceed to look at how India fit within
the broader global economy in that
period third we'll analyze the great
merchants and banking families in north
india who as we'll see not only
supported regional indian kingdoms but
who would also later play a critical
role in the emergence of british rule in
all we'll see how the regionalization of
the Mughal Empire coupled with broader
global economic trends combined with the
interest of India's great commercial
families all converged to provide what
we would call a recipe for colonialism
and it helps us understand how the
British later took advantage of these
dynamics to conquer India within two
generations now let's first start with
an overview of the Mughal Empire and its
eighteenth-century regionalization now
on the surface the Mughal Empire may
have looked the world's grandest but
beneath the surface there were
significant
changes taking place in regional
politics that would quickly unravel the
Mughal empires ability to govern in 1707
the last great Mughal emperor Aurangzeb
died yet his successors were weak and
far less effective in governing they
also were seemingly blind to changing
political realities in India and as
we've discussed in the previous lecture
the running of deaths in Mughal India
was crucial for naming enabling
zamindars Subedar Xand Maharaja's to
consolidate their own regional kingdoms
mainly in places such as Ovid Bengal and
Mysore mu coal wells and expansion had
come at a real cost the expansion and
military campaigns of Aurangzeb had
fiscally taxed the MU whole
administrative system and we also saw
how regional kingdoms emerged which
continued the spirit of the Mughal
emperor even if they were covertly
subverting his authority in Delhi
now let's go a bit deeper into this
regionalization what do regional
kingdoms do with each other everywhere
well let's think medieval Europe they
fight and compete usually over disputed
borders and access to resources so think
about it what skills and occupations
would be valuable to these kingdoms you
got it religious officiator x' scribes
and soldiers the emergence of competing
regional kingdoms in 18th century India
at a real dynamic effect it opened up
new sources of opportunity for revenue
hungry hungry states and numerous social
military and economic actors now let's
talk about religious officiate errs in
many regional states which sought to
penetrate deeper into the countryside
and tax and in the countryside this is
where most Hindus and Brahmins lived
both Hindu and Muslim rulers needed to
seek out the favour of Brahmins for
these rulers Brahmins are often the
source of power and legitimacy in the
countryside this is because they
provided if they are hindu rulers ritual
affirmation of hindu king but even if
the rulers were muslim brahmins carried
sway in society and deep into villages
giving Muslim rulers some theoretical
legitimacy thus
regional states that wanted their
cultivators to pay taxes often had to
have brahmins give it their okay now
another group which became sought-after
in 18th century India where pens men and
scribes pens mannan scribes were both
Hindu and Muslim they generally came
from less elite and landed backgrounds
but they were usually literate in
Persian accountancy and paper management
the largest group of Hindu scribes
kayasthas also became known as an almost
Islamist group who documented taxes
military finance and wrote Imperial
edicts they were so market because after
Brahmins kayasthas were the most
literate caste in all of India and since
many Brahmins refused to enter service
under Muslim rulers escaped eyes does an
open playing field Muslim scribes of
which they were far fewer were also
paper managers they had the advantage of
being Muslim for they faced fewer
barriers to patronage and employment
they often came from middle class
backgrounds were literate and held lands
but were neither politically nor
militarily elite now you might ask
yourself why would scribes be so sought
after I mean they managed paper think
taxes scribes were needed to manage the
increasingly paper driven fiscal regimes
of these regional kingdoms Hindu and
Muslim scribes became highly
sought-after employable after these
1720s they commanded skills in Persian
the language of court and administration
which made them crucial for regional
kingdoms that wanted to further in tax
and assess in north india for example
between Delhi and Calcutta kayasthas
emerged as the single greatest
beneficiary of the late Moog Hall and
18th century drive towards fiscal ISM
now if the pen was crucial for these
regional kingdoms the sword was equally
important after all regional kingdoms
seeking to expand conquer and enforce
rule all need steel gunpowder and muscle
everyone from common soldiers or see
poised to advisors and strategists saw
booming employment across India regional
states such as Mysore the Murat
the Confederacy and now odd built large
armies I would probably had over 50,000
standing troops the Maratha Confederacy
maintained an 80,000 plus standing force
mysore in the south also maintained tens
of thousands of troops larger armies
were a regular sight in 1700 india in
fact some historians have estimated that
around 2 percent of india's entire
population were in full-time uniform in
the 1700s and for you reservists and
veterans out there are all soldiers
full-time no there were also a
substantial number of part-time soldiers
given the vagaries of the monsoons
cultivators and farmers when faced with
bad harvests would often join armies
part-time to supplement their income in
fact coupled with full-time soldiery it
would be fair to say that probably close
to 5% of India's population was engaged
in direct warfare at some point during
any given year this is a far cry from
the utopian peaceful India that Gandhi
convinced many of us had always existed
and the rise of soldiery in India also
had substantial economic spillover
effects after all what the soldiers
often like to do with their money and
when they have free time well like most
people they spend it this is sort of an
Indian military economics complex
not only did soldiers need food and
uniforms and military hardware but also
entertainment thanks booze and sex
soldiers traditionally received a bata
or a military allowance which was their
disposable income bazaars were a
cauldron of military hardware whole
cross india you could find swords
matchlocks
gunpowder there were ken in foundries
across North India
needless to say Indian blacksmith castes
who made these specialized tools of
killing themselves made a killing if the
emergence of regional warfare also had
effects upon the environment of India
these kingdoms paid for armies with
taxes and taxes came from agriculture
but of course not in India like all
places not all of land is farmland
large uncultivated lands were inhabited
by forest dwellers and wandering
itinerant holy men in India for
thousands of years the Buddha himself
was one of perfect example starting in
the 1700s these regional kingdoms
started clearing forests they did this
for a few reasons first to increase the
amount of taxable arable land this meant
more revenue for the army court scribes
and general administration for some
kingdoms it could be the difference
between victory and defeat deforestation
offered tactical advantage as well
fewer cheat trees denied cover to the
enemy yet it also ensured that more
Indians would work the land as peasants
and farmers and as well see that the
shift towards greater agricultural labor
which we see in the 18th century was not
created by the British but later
accelerated it more intensely after
colonial rule now one event which
accelerated this military fiscal ISM
deserves particular mention in 1739 the
Afghan warrior nadir Shah invaded and
looted Delhi having defeated the armies
of the Mughal Emperor Mohammad Shah
nadir Shah reigned in Delhi his name was
read from main mosque in old delhi the
jama masjid which was the ultimate proof
of who ruled the Mughal Empire of course
though there was a darker side to this
now their Shahs soldiers went on a
massacre up to 20,000 people in Delhi
were killed as a revenge attack against
an attack on its troops by local Hindus
the city became in the words of one
Persian observer reduced to ashes the
Mughal emperor Mohammed Shah was
humiliated by being forced to beg on his
knees for mercy now their Shah looted so
much that historians have estimated he
made off with 15 million pound sterling
in 18th century money now this invasion
sent shockwaves throughout India's
regional kingdoms they all now felt they
had to bolster their armies and defenses
if the grand Mughal emperor could not
protect India then rulers in Bengal
Punjab and the Maratha lands in addition
to hobb had to bolster their own armies
themselves so if we step back for a
moment what we see is that all these
regional states practice something we
would call military fiscal ISM these
kingdoms were increasingly shifting
their spending and prerogatives towards
armies and this affected how agriculture
was expanded taxed and administered it
also greatly affected the rhythms of
India's regional economies and centres
of production for example kingdoms that
wanted to raise more revenue extended
agricultural cultivation into wastelands
they create forest DES placing forest
dwellers and tribal Adivasi or tribal
communities they settled lands that
required capital and credit which
brought Hindu merchants and moneylenders
into the picture newly settled lands
also required administrators inscribed
around which sprouted shops canteens so
you can imagine the spillover economic
stimulus effects and as we'll see in the
next lecture it was the British rather
than any Indian kingdom who would
eventually master this military fiscal
ISM by 1800 okay now that we've covered
the broader trend of political
regionalization let's look at how India
fit more broadly within the global
economy and this is crucial because for
it with economic motives that initially
brought the British to India we need to
understand what India offered
economically and why it mattered because
it was the strong European demand for
Indian goods at the end of the day that
also set the stage for European
involvement in India starting back in
the 1500s the Portuguese were the first
Europeans to try to get their hands on
India twelve they operated out of Goa
their colony on the west coast later in
the 1600s the English the Dutch and the
French also got involved mainly they
worked out of coastal settlements and
fortifications
they all competed with each other and
sought to intercept the flow of trade
between Southeast Asia India and the
Middle East that for centuries had been
dominated by Muslims but Europeans all
desired like India's Muslim conquerors
and rulers before
India's wealth and
potential spoils were massive by 1700
the Indian economy was a sophisticated
machine roughly a quarter of the world's
total Commerce passed through the Indian
subcontinent the Indian economy was
buoyant and hummed along with commercial
vibrancy Indian the 1700s was a great
exciting place for business and
opportunity its economy linked up
villages with larger all Indian networks
of commercial exchange mobility letters
of credit could originate in Bengal and
be cashed across the subcontinent in
western India merchant families for
example had branches across India and
even into Central Asia and it was the
vibrancy and buoyancy of India's economy
which was so attractive to Europeans for
European who visited in the 1700s India
was a great place for business the most
crucial items in the Indian economy at
the global level where textiles made
from cotton and jute Indian textiles
were the world's most sought after
between Europe Indonesia and well
everywhere the Indian artisanal economy
was designed primarily for export
Europeans increasingly demanded Indian
made cloths for shirts trousers
tablecloths napkins and tapestries in
some parts of Southeast Asia Indian
textiles were even accepted as a form of
currency and the English used Indian
textiles to pay for slaves off the west
coast of Africa hence the term we might
somewhat be familiar with Guinea cloth
so this is what India could offer the
global economy so it begs the question
what could Europe offer what fabric was
most common in Europe and you've got it
wool but our woolly jumpers useful in
the Middle East and Asia not really in
spite of this European commercial
interest increasingly came to punctuate
the indian economy after the early 1700s
most of all and most significantly the
English now one entity represented
England English and later after 1707
British commercial interests in India
the English East India Trading Company
the English East India Trading Company
was founded in 1600 by Queen Elizabeth
the first largely it's at the heads of
leading London merchants and traders who
wanted to effectively compete in the
India trade and with the Spanish and the
Portuguese it was one of the world's
first publicly traded joint stock
companies it was given a monopoly of
trade between India the East Indies and
England so if you were in English and
after 1707 a British subject you wanted
to trade legitimately in India you had
to go through the company now initially
the company did not have any political
aims in fact the company explicitly
wanted to avoid politics and power
struggles because engaging in them could
eat away at their potential profit and
since the company had shareholders
returns and dividends for Paramount if
the company dabbled in political
intrigue which endangered profits
shareholders might withdraw their
investment and demand payment so up
until the 1750s the British company and
the English East India Company largely
avoided getting involved in Indian
political affairs so as we've seen the
Indian economy was vibrant and the
British came from far away
unlike Arabs Persians and the Chinese
but the British did have a particular
advantage when it came to trading with
India one of these was silver silver was
the standard backing for India's various
rupee currencies the massive volume of
silver available to Europeans from South
America effectively gave the British
bullion that's the standard for their
currency but it needed to be extracted
melted and shipped all the way to India
thus one precondition for British power
was made possible by European access to
the new world and the large flows of
silver that were entering into Europe
the other advantage had to do with
navies and ships now we all know about
the Royal Navy's importance to British
history in 1600 remember the British had
just defeated the Spanish Armada and was
still fresh in people's memories this
bigger built up Navy also played out to
Britain's advantage in the Indian
subcontinent the Navy ensured that
Britain could command the long term
merit
I'm trade between India and the outside
world the British and Europeans sailed
from Europe around the southern african
tip all the way to India effectively
bypassing the old established land
routes of the Middle East in the
Mediterranean so europeans and the
british dominated the high route sea
route to india but indian empires
including the Mughals were largely
land-based
they were less interested in naval
forces besides everyone came to India
Indian traders and adventurers did not
need to go as far overseas in terms of
profit as did Europeans the other
advantage had to do with how the company
protected its trade in India since it
was far overseas and sometimes unknown
in hostile areas the company had its own
private mercenary force it had its own
private army the company had to protect
its physical safety and commercial
interests against various Nawabs armies
and the border invasions and incursions
that came to define 18th century India
and since the company like other
European trading companies in Asia had
no political responsibilities it didn't
have to abide by formal treaties or the
rules of warfare it was rather like the
black water of its time it used to
defend company's most valuable trading
fort in Calcutta but also its other
forts in Bombay and Madras this company
force also protected as much as it could
individual company traders up in the
Indian Interior but here is where the
real advantage comes into play it mostly
recruited Indian soldiers into its
private army why because they cost less
given its access to silver the company
was effectively able to pay better than
regional Indian kingdoms it paid its
soldiers more and more regularly it had
a better mercenary force it was
overwhelmingly composed of Indian
soldiers or CIPA he's under European
command and this was a regular and
better paid Force but the British also
had numerous disadvantages in terms of
India trade for one British trade and
present
was limited to the coast by the 1750s
they had not yet penetrated India's
internal economy and trade in wheat and
rice cloths minerals and others more
exotic textiles this is where the real
money was so they knew nothing of a
country interior trade were large
agrarian wealth lay and which had been a
source of wealth for kings and Sultan's
for thousands of years
also being far away and literally
stinking after the journey the British
and Europeans more generally we're never
really taken seriously by Indians and
the Mughals Europeans were not feared by
Indian rulers and traders Indian rulers
and traders often sell them as crude
violent barbarians who loved the bottle
because the other disadvantage was in
knowledge by the 1750s the British knew
very little about Indian customs rituals
and religions in the way they kind of
operated in the dark and it was only
after the conquests in the late 1700s
that knowledge of India's great
traditions and its broader civilization
opened up to scholars and eventually the
wider world
India's broader economy as we said was
buoyant and vibrant it attracted traders
from all over the world from Africa to
the Middle East to Southeast Asia the
Europeans were merely the latest round
of visitors seeking to make fortunes but
it is also fair to say that India's
economy was in the 1700s up for grabs
either a regional Indian or external
power was likely to command it
eventually so we have on the one hand a
vibrant Indian economy and on the other
hand an increasing drive for foreign
commercial interests in India and the
commercial opportunities it afforded we
put these together what do we get we get
a recipe for colonialism now that we've
covered the Indian economy and the
political regionalization of the Mughal
Empire let's now turn to look at the
great Indian commercial and banking
families for to understand the eventual
emergence of colonial rule you need to
look at Indian capital and Indian
commercial interests themselves these
are very much part of the equation let's
start by observing that
India was not a pure innocent victim of
colonial conquest there were a wider
collection of indigenous Indian
capitalist merchant bankers and money
lenders who are crucial in securing
British domination by 1800 these
merchants and banking families had
started to become very influential at
regional courts and for regional Indian
kingdoms in the 1700s for what do all
government even ours today always need
more of course money in the 1700s the
regional kingdoms of the Maratha
Confederacy Bengal Avadh Mysore all
needed more money and revenue to build
up their administration's they needed
bureaucrats scribes accountants
artillery stores provision you name it
with regional kingdoms competing over
contested territory fiscal might was
crucial less newly won territory
influenced fault regional rivals in
effect access to credit could insure
ones Armed Forces were more efficient
than one's neighbors so as we can see
Indian political rule was as much about
credit and fiscal might as it was about
armies and courts now historically
Hindus and James have served as India's
main moneylenders this is because for
Muslims they have largely shied away
from charging interest which they
largely considered usury even if Muslims
were known for their trading skills and
in weaving and the facilitation of trade
but when it came to finance and banking
hindus and james have no prohibitions
either of doctrinal or customary on
charging interest it would be fair to
call James India's true pacifists they
believe that everything has a soul and
that whole forms of killing are
unacceptable this means that they cannot
serve in the military or even harvest
root vegetables but for James money
lending and banking are both ritually
and spiritually clean now these banking
families had crucial advantages in the
indian economy particularly in india's
interior we're all of india's fiscal and
material wealth flowed by virtue of not
being muslim these families had easier
access to the interior of india's
agrarian wealth commerce and pilgrimage
cities such as
Mathura and Haridwar they moved grains
Goods and crucially long distance credit
bills called hundies which were honored
across most of India they could
originate in Calcutta
and be used in the Punjab kind of like a
Western Union money order some of these
families had become extremely wealthy
and influential by the mid 1700s the
jagat sets of Bengal for example had
larger holdings from the whole Bank of
England by 1750 in our wad to banking
families commanded probably half of the
Kingdom's annual revenue and it's here
where we see a major shift in India's
economic history previously the moon
halls and other rulers granted lay
trading in lead lending privileges to
these families but starting in the 1700s
with the opening up of this political
regionalization these families started
to lend to those in charge it was kind
of like a reversal of role so to speak
so what these families started to do was
to bankroll regional kingdoms Nawabs
King Sultan's and princes were extended
lines of credit and fought to finance
Wars and to build up administration's
and armies coupled with overall Indian
economic growth and European silver
these banking families were projected
into new positions of influence they
were now visible at the court and as one
French observer noted in the 1700s even
if they don't say much when they did
speak everyone particularly the King
listened very carefully there were other
economic factors related to land and
lending which started to dominate the
Indian economy previously under the
Mughals if someone could not pay their
taxes due then extensive negotiations
followed to arrange payments over time
or through other means or other members
of this landed family but landowners
rarely had their actual land seized
however in the heightened regional and
fiscal climate of 18th century India de
started to give way to an auctioneering
system of tax collection and land
ownership this auctioneering system
meant that if you owned land and
couldn't pay the revenue for which
you're responsible your lands might be
seized and
auction for the highest bidder this
started to break with established custom
which in the case of non-payment the
responsibility for this payment would
shift to someone else and family but the
fiscal in some of these kingdoms started
to basically throw the concept of
private property out the window and this
is where the banking and money lending
families of India come into play being
moneyed they could now bid for these
lands in the right to collect revenue
and this is really significant for it
put more money minded castes who are
largely by shows into the ownership of
larger estates which then colored the
ways Indian peasants were taxed and
assessed and indeed treated and this
mattered because it is this is this what
the British encountered and eventually
accelerated with savage intensity after
the 1780s this pressure on land was
further exacerbated by European demand
for Indian textiles since indigo cotton
silk and jute were required for
exportable textiles greater European
demand led regional kingdoms to tax
Commerce less and the landed economy
more and when demand and profitability
were greater so were the severity and
the intensity of tax collections now
even though these banking families were
becoming more important and influential
they also tended to bump up against the
prog ative courts regional Kings in
Awadh Mysore and Bengal for example
required generous lines of credit to
maintain armies administrations between
harvests it but they tended to squeeze
Hindu and Jain banking families and
their with their demands and terms now
think about it if you were a banker and
your ruler started to squeeze you what
might you consider well these banking
and merchant families started to do a
few things in the 1700s one they slowly
started to withdraw their support for
regional kingdoms and two there was the
possibility that they might throw in
their lot with an external power who to
them seemingly offered better agreements
in terms of security and profitability
this is where the British would come in
later now we've covered quite a lot so
let's
cap what we've examined in this lecture
and try to make broader sense of it and
what this means for the emergence of
British colonial rule first we reviewed
the regionalization of the Mughal Empire
throughout the seventeen hundreds and
how the Mucca Mucca empires rule was
decentralized into regional kingdoms
mainly mysore Awadh and bengal all of
these kingdoms have been building up
their state systems and importantly
their revenue capabilities second we
proceeded to look at how Indians sit
within the broader global economy in the
early 1700s we saw that it was a major
part of the global economy and that it
was an economy which exported finished
textiles all over the world we also
looked at the advantages and
disadvantage the British had in Indian
trade thirdly we analyzed the great
merchants and banking families of North
India we saw how they supported regional
Indian kingdoms through credit commerce
and supplies and that they had become
prominent players in the regional
politics and the courts of these
kingdoms given all these facts what were
the prospects for colonial rule at this
point how did they look good bad
inevitable it's a hard question to
answer in hindsight the prospects for
colonial rule looked good but he
certainly were not inevitable broader
dynamics of 18th century India opened up
a possibility that any Indian regional
power could rise to become the dominant
power in the subcontinent and this is
where the English ended up in the right
place at the right time it seemed
impossible in 1750 that this private
company from overseas would end up
masters of an Indian subcontinent by
1820 but this is exactly what happened
the company would take advantage of the
very dynamics and trends we discussed
and who would exploit them more
ruthlessly than any other Indian Kingdom
the result was that the company would
end up channeling these economic forces
on British not Indian terms and as an
outside power it could play one Indian
power off another rather than
replicating Caesars conquest of Gaul for
Rome the British would not pull off a
veni vidi vici or I came I saw I
conquered
rather they would take advantage of
processes that had already been
transpiring in India from the early 17
onwards